most trees have been discovered and
given in scientific name and put into
the scientific literature
with fungi it's almost the reverse fewer
than 10 percent
actually been discovered and named this
new
organization called the society for the
protection of underground networks they
had gotten quite a large amount of money
from a foundation
seemed pretty unique to have a whole
society devoted just to one kind of
fungi the kind that makes these
underground networks
the researchers were able to use
thousands of samples that have been
collected geo-located are all in this
database to feed into their computer
model to tell them where to go different
areas of the map
popped up as potentially having a lot of
interesting fungi that hadn't been
studied and
certain parts of chile were among those
this area is known as the lungs of
southern chile because the forests are
so rich and producing so much oxygen
but you can think of the underground as
the circulatory system to match that
forest
toby she's really pioneered methods for
studying fungi in the lab at a very
micro scale she has partnered with
giuliana furchi who's a field scientist
she helped get this law passed in chile
that formerly protects fungi if we don't
look after the underground reservoirs of
biodiversity we won't have the symbiotic
organisms that we need for trees to
establish in degraded lands
then a third major player in it was
merlin sheldrake
who's a british independent mycologist
we are sampling soil at different sites
by a grid of nine points we mix this
together and to create one sample
which we'll then take to a lab we
extract the dna from all of the
organisms in the soil
and then we sequence the dna which will
help us to find out who's living here
and we combine them into a very very
large data set which allows us to make
maps of the world's mycorrhizal fungal
networks and to make predictions about
what we expect to find these maps will
then be able to
form a basis for conservation
initiatives
there are places where these computer
models suggest there might be high
fungal biodiversity that are not
necessarily being protected for what's
above ground
one of the arguments for putting more
effort towards studying fungi is that
many of them could have important uses
that we don't know about
these tiny arbuscular mycorrhizal fungi
we could be using them potentially to
grow
healthier forests faster growing tree
plantations to produce more wood on a
smaller area perhaps that which would
allow
the protection of other forests that
don't need to be logged
people think that
fungi could play a role in climate
change because the fungi take up carbon
and then some of that carbon might stay
in the soil long term
a few people i spoke with or kind of
interacted with who
seemed to feel like despite being one of
the biggest efforts to go out and study
fungi at the global scale it might
actually not be big enough to really
actually accomplish its goals
the scientists are not going to be able
to sample everywhere
so one of the ways they're trying to get
around that is to
give out these mini grants to
mycologists
in different parts of the world
and then those people will go out and
sample in their own regions
they have goals to sample mongolia
africa a remote island in the pacific
we're aiming in the next 18 months to
get 10 000 samples and if you imagine
that each one of those samples is nine
different points where we actually put
this core into the earth it's 90 000
times where we just have to pause
and think with all of our intentions
what is under here and what
mysteries are we gonna unveil
[Music]